it is a long and nervy walk to the front
line trenches around back moves
as we make our way through Woodlands the
war crashes around us
to get to the defensive positions means
leaving cover
Russian drones are looking for movement
targets for their artillery
in the trenches the soldiers are
hardened to the dangers
and from here you can see the city up
close
back moot appears like a vision from a
nightmare
the buildings just blackened bones of a
place where people used to live
we watch as shell off the shell is
Unleashed on this city under siege this
is one of the main front lines from
where they are defending the city of
back moot
the shelling here is continuous
we've had the sound of incoming fire
almost from the moment that we got here
but you can see the damage you can make
out the damage to the city
there's just smoke across the horizon
the men who are its Defenders tell us
they are only holding on but they will
not give up
[Music]
you know
resume
further along the front line is chasive
yar
Russia controls nearly all of back moves
and this town could be next
the soldiers show me where Putin's
forces are moving
at the command center they know the main
counter-offensive is looming
and until it starts they must keep
Russia from advancing further
it is not easy
we fight for
all the power we had and I don't know
it's actually very difficult and uh
scary situation
this war is exacting a terrible price on
Ukraine the donbass where the fighting
is most Savage has forced the majority
from their homes
here shells land in streets without
warning
every building is battered
and moscow's indiscriminate use of
violence is getting worse
the bomb that caused this crater in
chromatosk landed in the middle of the
night next to a block of flats
there is no military Target here
only civilians
and they are terrified
yeah
if starting
um
and as they clear up the devastation
they call loved ones to reassure them
they are okay
each day brings more Carnage
and each day this war goes on there is
less hope
Alex Rossi's Sky News eastern Ukraine